Okay, question. I can take my Dutch test samples beginning next Thursday. Do I stop taking
my supplements three days prior? I called precision diagnostics, and they said that I can
do that, especially with the high dose melatonin, because that is a hormone can affect the other
hormones. However, they said that if you want results without the effects of dim estrogen,
then you'll really have to stop that two to four weeks prior. You think it's a good idea to take
the dim to see how that is working. My previous Dutch test was in 2021, and there were no huge red
flags, so I don't know if we care about comparison. I'm not sure I want to stop taking my dim. They say
to note the melatonin if I continue to take it. So there's different, two different ways when you're
looking at a functional lab like this. It's similar to testing for food sensitivities. If you
really want to push the boundary of food sensitivity so you're concerned about gluten, then you
would purposely eat more gluten before running the lab, which is not highly advisable with gluten. But
there are some people that will stay, if they've been staying off gluten, then their lab can actually show
no antibodies to gluten, and they think you're going to need it. Well, it's showing no antibodies,
but doesn't mean their body won't bake antibodies if they go and eat gluten. So I tend to fall on the side of
live how you normally live and run the test how you normally live. Same thing with hormones, hormones
fluctuate day to day. So if you're if you want to have, so if your purpose was in this case with the
Dutch test, if their purpose was I don't want to be taken by dim forever. So I want to know how my hormones
would do without taking the dim, then I would say, then if that's what you want to find out,
then I would say go off of it for four weeks and see how your hormones, what the balance is,
after being off of it for four weeks. But in a perfect world, you would do that and then okay,
if they're normal, I'm going to stay off and dim. I would redo the test maybe in three months to see
if it stays that way because your body could change. But if that's not your concern, my concern is
to get off and dim, I want to just keep my I don't want this cancer to come back. I want to keep my
estrogen levels down. Then I would keep that I would purpose I would I would purposely keep taking
the dim because I want to know what my hormones levels are like when I'm doing what I will normally do
and what I will continue to do, which is take the dim. Now I don't think there's anything wrong with
going off the melatonin for several days beforehand because that may be something you're not going to
stay on for the rest of your life. But I would follow into the camp that I would keep taking the dim,
note it on there and I would probably stop taking the melatonin and note it on there that you were taking it.